I was asked how can we lift up the
entire Global community
it's easy but for some reason so
difficult to do
just be good with each other
you know
um
we have more resources than we've ever
had in our lives
the capacity of doing good things to
help each other
um would give us the best resources an
allocation it would be great it's like
the commonality across all religions
what is the common themes across all
major religions do unto others as you
would have them do unto you or the
concept of Karma what you what goes
around comes around if you are generous
and you think of the common good and so
on we would have a wonderful
Society
that's what we that's all we need to do